[typing noises,
message alerts]
- WHAT'S YOUR STORY?
TALK TO ME.
- WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE, I
WANNA EXPAND MY SINGING CAREER
TO BE, LIKE, A MICHAEL-JACKSON
LEVEL ENTERTAINER.
- OBVIOUSLY, LIKE,
A COLLABORATION WITH ME,
LIKE, THAT KIND OF STUFF
IS POSSIBLE, NO DOUBT, OKAY?
- YEAH, YOU SEEM LIKE YOU
PROBABLY WOULD DO, LIKE,
GOOD BUSINESS IN TERMS OF SO
MANY SHADY PEOPLE OUT THERE
AND CROOKED AND, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, SHYSTERS.
BUT YOU SEEM LIKE A REAL,
REAL, DOWN TO EARTH DUDE.
- "IMPLISH-ITLY."
YOU COULD ABSOLUTELY,
IMPLISH-ITLY TRUST ME.
- I'M GONNA BRING 110%
TO THE TABLE ON A DAILY BASIS.
SO ONE THING I WOULD DO IS,
LIKE, THIS.
- OKAY, THAT'S GREAT.
YEAH, 'CAUSE IT'S, LIKE,
I COULD SEE MYSELF SHOOTING
ON YOUR FACE OR SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE RESPECTFUL.
- [giggles]
LOT OF PEOPLE SAY
I HAVE A REAL CUTE LAUGH.
IT'S LIKE...
[annoying laugh]
- OH, THAT'S A GREAT LAUGH.
- [continues laughing]
- [laughs]
I THINK OF MYSELF AS, LIKE,
A VERY COOL,
VERY WHITE JAY-Z.
- YEAH. YEAH.
- I'M STRAIGHT-UP
LOOKING FOR BEYONCE.
- WOW. THAT'S GREAT!
- LIKE FIRST AND FIRST MOSTLY,
FOR ME, IT'S ABOUT FAMILY.
- YEAH.
- SO WHETHER IT'S, LIKE--
WHETHER IT'S, LIKE,
REAL FAMILY,
[tearing up]
LIKE MY FAMILY, LIKE MY MOTHER--
I MEAN, LIKE, ARE YOU VERY
SERIOUS ABOUT SINGING? LIKE--
- I FEEL LIKE
I COULD LEARN FROM YOU
IN TERMS OF,
I HAVE SO MANY MENTORS,
BUT YOU WOULD BE,
LIKE, THE REAL DEAL.
- YOU JUST SAY YOU HAVE MANY
MENTORS AND THAT, LIKE--
- BUT THAT'S,
LIKE, IN THE PAST.
- 'CAUSE I FEEL LIKE
I BEEN HURT BEFORE
AS FAR AS, LIKE,
COLLABORATING WITH WOMEN.
AND I'M TRYING TO SLEEP WITH
THEM, FIND OUT THAT THEY'RE
USING OTHER MEN
IN A SIMILAR FASHION
THAT I'M TRYING
TO USE THEM.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING?
- I'M TRYING TO, IT'S LIKE,
CERTAIN WORDS I DON'T KNOW.
- THIS FEELS CRAZY, RIGHT?
- THIS IS CRAZY,
IT'S LIKE,
I'VE BEEN HURT TOO,
AND IT'S, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S REALLY GOOD TO FEEL,
LIKE, EXTRA SAFE
WITH SOMEBODY RIGHT NOW,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S LIKE,
WE DON'T KNOW,
DO WE GO FROM A BUSINESS ZONE
INTO MANY OTHER ZONES
AS WELL?
- THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING,
STRAIGHT-UP.
- LIKE, IN THE BED,
JUST LIKE TALKING
AND TELLING SECRETS AND STUFF?
- TELLING SECRETS.
CAN I TELL YOU A SECRET?
- YEAH.
- I WILL BEAT--
- BOBBY?
- WHAT'S--
- BOBBY.
UH...
- IS THAT YOUR SECRETARY?
- YEAH, THAT'S, LIKE, BASICALLY,
LIKE, MY SECRETARY.
- OKAY. OKAY.
- EXCUSE ME.
- THAT'S COOL, YOU--
HI, I'M FARLEY. HELLO.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
- VERY NICE TO MEET YOU TOO,
BUT I'M NOT HIS SECRETARY,
I'M HIS MOTHER.
- EXCUSE ME.
NO DISRESPECT. ONE SECOND.
- BOBBY?
EXCUSE US.
I JUST WANTED TO TELL YOU...
- YEAH?
- THAT I LOVE YOU.
- I LOVE YOU SO MUCH, MOM.
- I LOVE YOU, BABY.
- FARLEY?
- GOOD. SHE'S GONE.
- FARLEY, WHERE'D YOU GO?
[door slams]
- NOW!
- OKAY, MA.
- DINNER.
- I'M COMING DOWN, SWEETHEART.
I LOVE YOU, MA.
- I LOVE YOU, BABY.
- I LOVE YOU TOO, MA.
- IT'S ALMOST COLD.
[crying]
- I'LL COME DOWN!